liebe genossinnen und genossen liebe
freundinnen und freunde verehrte gäste
heute spreche ich letzten mal ich als
vorsitzender unserer bundestagsfraktion
auf einem unserer parteitage die
legislaturperiode des
fraktionsvorstandes endet im herbst 2015
ich werde nicht erneut kandidieren da
die zeit gekommen ist den vorsitz
unserer fraktion in jüngere hände zu
legen
der vorstand unserer fraktion beschloss
am 13 oktober 2015 wahlen der neuen
vorsitzenden abzuhalten
die wahlen für den übrigen
fraktionsvorstand finden am dritten
november 2015 statt
die entscheidung für den 13
oktober ist schon deshalb wichtig weil
die zahl 13 wie ich finde eine
glückszahl ist unsere beiden
parteivorsitzenden katja kipping und
bernd riexinger
so haben wir es in der geschäftsordnung
der fraktion geregelt besitzen ein
vorschlagsrecht für meine nachfolgerin
und meinen nachfolger
sie haben damit eine große verantwortung
die wir ihn nicht durch ausufernde
personaldebatten erschweren sollten sie
werden nach beratungen für die
selbstverständlich auch ich zur
verfügung stehe
von ihrem recht gebrauch machen und eine
kandidatin und einen kandidaten
vorschlagen
außerdem darf selbstverständlich jedes
mitglied der fraktion auch von sich aus
kandidieren ich möchte einige wenige
bemerkung zu meiner entscheidung man im
mai 2013 sah sich mit verantwortlichen
genossinnen und genossen des
parteivorstandes und der fraktion vor
der bundestagswahl zusammen und habe
ihnen erklärt dass ich wüsste dass die
hauptlast des wahlkampfes auf mehr als
einem der spitzenkandidaten liegen werde
ich sagte dass sich dies auch in ordnung
finde aber niemals wählerinnen und
wähler betrügen und deshalb erneut
anschließend für das amt des
fraktionsvorsitzenden kandidieren
ferner erklärte ich ihnen dass ich nach
einer legislaturperiode des
fraktionsvorstandes also im herbst 2015
nicht wieder kandidieren werde
diese entscheidung hatte ich damals
bekannt gegeben so dass sich versichern
kann dass spätere erklärungen oder
empfehlungen von personen oder gremien
der partei nichts aber auch gar nichts
damit zu tun haben da ich in berlin
treptow köpenick direkt für vier jahre
in den bundestag gewählt worden bin ist
auch klar dass ich nach dem ausscheiden
aus dem fraktionsvorstand mitglied des
bundestages bleibe ich hoffe sogar
ich hoffe sogar dann etwas mehr zeit für
meinen wahlkreis zu finden die frage ob
ich 2017 versuche erneut für den
bundestag zu kandidieren kann ich heute
noch nicht beantworten
ich werde diese entscheidung im jahr
2016 treffen
selbstverständlich ist dass ich meine
verantwortung als fraktionsvorsitzender
bis zum 13 oktober 2015 vollständig
wahrnehmen werde
und ebenso selbstverständlich ist für
mich dass ich dank die verantwortung
wirklich abgeben
das heißt nicht heimlich versuchen werde
die fraktion auf indirekte art weiter
zunehmen in letzter zeit haben viele
angefangen meine entscheidung vom mai
2013 ernst zu nehmen zumindest noch
ernster zu nehmen sie haben mit mir
gesprochen um mich zu einer anderen
entscheidung zu bewegen
noch nie war die zustimmung zu mir in
der fraktion so groß wie jetzt
übrigens hat ein abgeordneter
das hat mir auch gefallen zu mir gesagt
dass ich für ihn das kleinere übel sei
und deshalb unbedingt bleiben solle ich
bin ihm dankbar denn jetzt weiß ich
endlich was das kleinere übel ist
nämlich
und ich weiß auch dass die partei und
ich in der gesellschaft einer nicht ganz
unbeachtlichen akzeptanz schub genommen
haben all das freut mich wirklich sehr
und ich möchte mich bei allen die mit
mir darüber diesbezüglich gesprochen
haben herzlich bedanken aber ich glaube
dass man gerade in einer solchen phase
und mit 67 jahren eine solche
verantwortung abgeben sollte und nicht
erst wenn ihr seit geraumer zeit denkt
war nicht endlich aufhören in den ersten
jahren meiner politischen tätigkeit
begegneten mir fast nur extreme entweder
wurde ich geliebt fast angebetet oder
gehasst
beides ist sehr anstrengend hast deshalb
weil man mit sich selbst nicht klar
kommt ich verstand die ablehnung nicht
ich wusste nicht was ich den leuten
getan hatte aber die tiefe zuneigung war
noch schlimmer weil ich wusste dass sich
die wünsche der menschen nicht erfüllen
konnte und es tat mir so weh sie
enttäuschen zu müssen
ihr werdet euch wundern aber damals war
es für mich im westen leichter obwohl
wir dort ziemlich chancenlos waren
vielleicht auch weil wir dort chancenlos
war trotzdem vergisst man nicht wer
anfangs damals noch von einem lang
anderem land mit einem sprach- und
wendig im jahr 1990 besuchte mich antje
vollmer von den grünen der inzwischen
leider verstorbene harry rostock und
egon bahr beide sozialdemokraten
wir sprachen intensiv miteinander und
ich möchte mich heute bei antje vollmer
und egon bahr dafür bedanken aristo blut
mich übrigens 1990 zu seiner
laubenpieper party ein
die alljährlich im frühjahr durchführte
er teilte mir dann mit dass die hälfte
seiner gäste wegen der einladung an mich
abgesagt hätte ich sagte ihm dass mir
das leid tue und ich ja nicht zu kommen
brauche er sagte ich müsse auf jeden
fall kommen weil die hälfte die abgesagt
hatte wie nicht mehr interessiere
das hat mir
informieren
ich habe dann hass und ablehnung auch im
bundestag gespürt ich weiß welche
journalisten gegen mich ermittelt haben
und in jeder weise gegen mich
vorgegangen sind und vorgehen
ich weiß wie viele prozesse ich führen
wie sehr ich um meinen ruf kämpfen
musste ich werde die anhörung im
immunitätsausschuss des bundestages nie
vergessen
übrigens hat die fdp trotz gravierender
politischer meinungsunterschiede bei mir
für immer einen kleinen stein im brett
weil sie neben meiner fraktion die
einzige war
die beim einer verurteilung nicht
mitmacht den rechtsstaat habe ich zu
schätzen gelernt denn die gerichte gaben
mir recht und nicht den anderen die
staatsanwaltschaften stellten die
ermittlungen gegen mich ein wollen es
zumindest
weil sie sich nicht missbrauchen ließen
und lassen
gerade weil ich auch in einer diktatur
gelebt habe kann ich euch nur raten die
rechtsstaatlichkeit hoch zu schätzen und
sie immer zu schützen
auch wenn einem die gerichtsurteile
logischerweise nicht immer gefallen
dieser phase gab es viel solidarität aus
meiner partei für die ich mich bedanken
möchte ebenso möchte ich mich bei denen
bedanken die mich einlud
obwohl sie sich ärger einhandeln und ich
möchte mich bei den journalistinnen und
journalisten bedanken die mich damals
gerade in talkshows holten und das bei
ihren redaktions leitungen durchsetzen
oder die fähre interviews in zeitungen
mit mehr führten so dass sie chancen
bekam das bild über unsere partei und
mich zu korrigieren
ich werde nicht anfangen einzelne leute
auf meinen politischen weg zu würdigen
weil ich wichtige vergesse was sie mir
übel nehmen und ich mir selbst noch viel
übernehme aber ich möchte hans motto
würden
der als vorletzter ministerpräsident der
ddr eine höchst komplizierte und sehr
verantwortliche tätigkeit leistete die
zu viel zu wenig viel zu selten auch von
uns gewürdigt wird ich weiß hans
ich weiß hans dass wir nie eng
befreundet waren aber du sollst wissen
dass ich dich immer geschätzt habe
und auch heute schätze außerdem muss ich
euch von dem küchenkabinett erzählen
dessen ruf so war dass man es nicht in
ordnung fand dass es dieses überhaupt
gab und sich gleichzeitig freute dass es
existierte dazu gehörten lothar bisky
dessen tut mir sehr zu schaffen gemacht
hat michael schumann dessen tod ebenso
furchtbar für mich war dietmar bartsch
andré brie heinz vietze und ich
natürlich wurden gelegentlich auch
weitere personen hinzu gezogen aber eine
truppe war das schon
und wenn wir uns auf meinem damaligen
grundstück in buckow trafen haben wir
alles wichtige besprochen
oft auch geklärt allerdings haben wir
auch sehr gut gegessen und nicht
schlecht getrunken um es ehrlich zu sein
diesen kabinett zählte zweifellos die
demokratische legitimität aber in der
damaligen zeit ging es nicht anders dazu
waren die angriffe auf die partei viel
zu schwer wiegen und ich weiß es gab ein
problem bei diesem kabinett die
quotierung aber ich versichere euch
unter den sechs war zumindest ein in
jeder hinsicht ausgewiesener für
minister ich sage euch aber nicht wer es
war
bedanken wenn ich mich aber heute und
ausdrücklich bei dietmar bartsch andré
brie und heinz pitzer
beachtlich war dass es mir bei der
bundestagswahl 1994 94 gelangen drei
höchst unterschiedliche hervorragende
ältere persönlichkeiten für unsere
fraktionen zu gewinnen heinrich graf
einzigen wehrmachtsoffizier dann
mitglied des nationalkomitees freies
deutschland
er verließ die ddr galt dann aber in der
brd vielfach als verräter ein
parteiloser sehr feiner eleganter kluger
und kritischer geist stefan heym ein
jude der wegen der nazis emigrieren
musste dann in den streitkräften der usa
gegen hitler kämpfte ein herausragender
schriftsteller der schonungslos den
staatssozialismus kritisierte als er als
parteiloser alterspräsident im bundestag
1994 eröffnete brachten die abgeordneten
der cdu/csu ihre missachtung gegenüber
zum ausdruck was nur sie selbst
beschädigt
beide sind inzwischen verstorben märz
während der die ddr in den 50er jahren
verließ ist ein sehr wacher und
analytischer geist dieser schriftsteller
bezeichnete sich auf einem unserer
partei dabei als antikommunisten und
erklärte uns dass es davon auch eine
demokratische linke variante gebe vor
kurzem wurde er 90 jahre alt und ich
will ihm und ich denke auch in eurem
namen noch einmal herzlich gratulieren
wenn diese drei männer bundestag
erschienen und redeten konnte man den
abgeordneten der anderen fraktionen den
night im gesicht buchstäblich ablesen
und wir waren zu recht stolz großes
glück hatte ich mit allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern die
mir im parteivorstand und dem bundestag
direkt oder indirekt zugeordnet waren
ich denke an die fahrer die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die mir
bei der politischen arbeit helfen helfen
an die die für mich organisierten und
schrieben sie alle waren
hundertprozentig loyal sehr fleißig
solidarisch und schufen mir eine
angenehme atmosphäre arbeitsatmosphäre
bei ihnen will ich mich herzlich
bedanken
aus der sed eine pds zu transformieren
war ein ungeheuer eine ungeheuer schwere
aufgabe wie konnte ein wirklicher drang
zur freiheit und demokratie erreicht
werden wie konnte man sozialistisch
bleiben ohne als anhängerin bzw anhänger
des gescheiterten staatssozialismus zu
gelten es gab zunächst massenhaft aus
dritten den wunsch nach auflösung aber
auch den wunsch nach reformen dass es
uns gelungen ist die partei so
umzukrempeln und schritt für schritt die
akzeptanz im osten zu erweitern
das war eine leistung auf die wir stolz
sein können
trotzdem das projekt pds wäre
ausgelaufen weil es kulturell nur
äußerst geringe chancen in den alten
bundesländern hatte deshalb weil die
vereinigung von der partei des
demokratischen sozialismus mit der
wahlalternative arbeit und soziale
gerechtigkeit zur partei die linke ein
so wichtiger akt egal wie die
entwicklung danach im einzelnen
beurteilt werden
aus den alten bundesländern haben sich
hierbei oskar lafontaine klaus ernst und
thomas händel besondere verdienste
erworben
machen wir uns nichts vor ohne oskar
lafontaine hätte das ganze nicht
geklappt wäre auch ich übrigens nicht in
die politik zurückgekehrt
auch wenn sich unsere anteile an
wählerinnen und wählern und ost und west
nach wie vor gravierend unterscheiden
wir sind inzwischen eine bedeutende
politische kraft in der bundesrepublik
deutschland wir sind wer hätte sich das
frühjahr vorstellen können
oppositionsführerin im deutschen
bundestag
inzwischen werden wir auch mit unserer
scharfen kritik am abhörskandal
gegenüber unserer bevölkerung an der
wirtschaftsspionage und an der
beschädigung der beziehungen zu unseren
europäischen nachbarn durch die nse der
beihilfe durch den bnd und dem schweigen
und verschweigen die bundes durch die
bundesregierung ernst genommen und
gehört die frage ist was sollte unsere
partei auszeichnet wir brauchen ein
zutiefst kritisches verhältnis zum
staatssozialismus also auch zur ddr
wir müssen die einschränkungen von
freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit deutlich
herausarbeiten und so glaubhaft wie
möglich garantieren dass wir ein
höchstmaß an freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit anstreben
wir müssen herausarbeiten weshalb die
wirtschaft nicht funktioniert
den mangel an produktivität produkten
und dienstleistungen wir müssen für die
zukunft garantieren dass es auch mit uns
eine hohe produktivität eine
funktionierende wirtschaft und keine
mangelwirtschaft geben wird viel zu
wenig wird mit uns eine funktionierende
wirtschaft verbunden
das muss sich ändern andererseits dürfen
wir aber nicht zulassen dass das bild
von der ddr die leistungen der menschen
dort und ihre biografien so arrogant so
von außen und ohne kenntnis gewertet
werden
es gab beachtliche soziale und
kulturelle leistung
es gab leider eine politische
ausgrenzung auch in der bildung die es
nie hätte geben dürfen
aber es gab keine soziale ausgrenzung
wie wir sie heute massenhaft erleben
der zugang zu bildung kunst und kultur
war für jede und jeden in der ddr im
unterschied zu heute bezahlbar wenn wir
wenn wir das richtige maß an deutlicher
kritik auf der einen seite und an
respekt auf der anderen seite finden
dann sind wir glaubwürdig
zweitens wenn wir sozialistisch bleiben
wollen müssen wir erklären was uns und
warum am kapitalismus stört auch was uns
nicht stört sondern im gegenteil gutes
und wie man das störende überwinden und
das andere erhalten kann gegen eine
kapitalistische diktatur ist die
anwendung von gewalt gerechtfertigt um
sie zu überwinden braucht man eine
revolution wir aber leben in einer
politischen demokratie deshalb kommt für
uns nur der gewaltfreie weg der
transformation in frage
wir müssen versuchen eine mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land von unserem weg
zu überzeugen
wenn uns das nicht gelingt haben wir das
nicht das recht sie zu unserem weg zu
zwingen
aber was funktioniert am kapitalismus
und was nicht
der kapitalismus kann eine höchst
effiziente und produktive wirtschaft
hervorbringen es gibt so gut wie nie
einen mangel an waren und
dienstleistungen steht der profit über
alle ein medikament für seltene
krankheiten rechnet sich nicht und wird
so gut wie nie entwickelt die großen
banken und konzerne haben eine übergroße
und demokratie gefährdenden macht sie
organisieren für sich eine
funktionierende weltwirtschaft nehmen
alle steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
in haftung und es steht ihnen nicht
einmal im ansatz eine funktionierende
weltpolitik gegenüber
wenn wir über eine einschränkung der
macht der großen banken und konzerne
nicht nur reden sondern sie tatsächlich
erreichen wollen brauchen wir das
bündnis mit dem mittelstand auch ihn
stört die marktdominanz der großen
privaten banken und konzerne
ihn stört auch dass sie selbst
pleitegehen dürfen die anderen aber
nicht
ihn stört dass er ehrlich steuern
bezahlen muss während sich die konzerne
und großen privaten banken erfolgreich
davor drücken
ein solches breiten bündnis brauchen wir
also aber es darf kein zweckbündnis sein
wir müssen es ernst meinen sie dürfen
nicht den eindruck haben dass wir sie
über die steuern kaputt machen wollen
klar muss für uns und sie seien
das ist unsere pflicht ist die
schwächsten in unserer gesellschaft dann
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
aber eben auch die breite mitte der
gesellschaft zu vertreten
das heißt wir sollten eine partei sein
die die interessen der obdachlosen der
asylbewerberin und asylbewerber der
flüchtlinge der hartz iv empfängerinnen
und hartz4 empfänger der arbeitslosen
aber ganz entschieden auch der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern der
rentnerinnen und rentner
auch der bäuerinnen und bauern der
beamtinnen und beamten
nicht zu vergessen der kinder und
jugendlichen der menschen mit
behinderungen der freiberuflerinnen und
freiberufler der selbstständigen
der kleinen und mittleren unternehmen
und unternehmer vertreten
das aber bedeutet dass wir mit unserem
vorschlag von einem spitzensteuersatz
von 53 prozent bei der einkommenssteuer
nicht zu früh anfangen dürfen wir
sollten nicht die mitte der gesellschaft
treffen
ich finde der spitzensteuersatz sollte
für das einkommen gelten dass bei einer
ledigen bzw einem ledigen über 1000 euro
brutto pro jahr liegt darüber wird beim
nächsten ball programm zu diskutieren
sein
übrigens egal ob in brandenburg oder in
berlin
wenn wir den wirtschaftsminister oder
den wirtschaftssenator stellten
funktionierte die wirtschaft gut
ich finde wir sollten aufhören die super
schweigen und im gegenteil beginnen mit
stolz darauf zu verweisen
wir sollten dafür streiten dass die
öffentliche daseinsvorsorge
ausschließlich in öffentlicher hand
gehört dafür dass die großen
privatbanken verkleinert und
öffentlich-rechtlich für die sparkassen
gestaltet werden alle unternehmerinnen
und unternehmer sollten wissen dass wir
immer für mehr demokratie in unternehmen
das heißt für mehr mitbestimmung und für
angemessene und gerechte löhne streiten
werden aber sie sollen bis zum
mittelstand auch wissen dass wir das
bündnis mit ihnen ehrlich suchen auch
ihre interessen vertreten
ich werde häufig gefragt ob ich denn
wirklich glaubte dass mittelständlerin
und mittelständler uns wählten
abgesehen von ausnahmen wird das nicht
der fall sein
ihr müsst aber folgendes beachten
mittelständische unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer haben auf den größten teil
ihrer arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
deutlich mehr einfluss als wir
wenn sie ihren arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern erklären dass sie ins
ausland gehen falls wir an die regierung
kämen oder kurz vor der insolvenz
stünden wird es viele arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer geben die uns nicht
werden
wenn wir das angesprochene bündnis
ehrlich einging sagten zu sie zu ihren
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern in
etwa na ja die linken sehe ich mal so
mal so
das ist schon eine generelle erlaubnis
für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer uns zu wählen
unterschätzt diese seite nicht der
kapitalismus kann keinen frieden sichern
das hat mindestens zwei gründe es geht
um die eroberung von märkten und es wird
am krieg zu viel verdient deshalb sind
unsere forderungen nach einem verbot von
rüstungsexporten und nach der
überwindung von privater
rüstungsproduktion besonders wichtig wir
sind und müssen eine friedenspartei sein
und bleiben
der kapitalismus bringt andererseits
hervorragende leistungen auf den
gebieten der forschung wissenschaft
kunst und kultur hervor wir müssen aber
einen zunehmenden kulturabbau ebenso
bekämpfen wie wir uns dafür einzusetzen
haben den chancengleichen zugang zu
kunst kultur und bildung zu ermöglichen
wir müssen die entschiedensten kämpfer
auch dort gegen soziale ausgrenzung
seien der letzte zweck von politik muss
ein mehr an kultur sei
wir brauchen als partei wieder viel
engere gesprächskontakte zu
künstlerinnen und künstlern zu
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern
sie sehen dinge anders als wir und es
ist für uns so wichtig die partei und
uns selbst auch mal anders gesehen zu
bekommen der kapitalismus ist sozial
höchst ungerecht
es gibt eine zunehmende tendenz den
reichtum in wenigen händen zu
konzentrieren und die armut zu
verbreiten
das ist eine katastrophe und führt zu
not elend und hunger
jährlich sterben durchschnittlich 70
millionen menschen auf der erde
die häufigste ursache ist der hunger
obwohl wir eine landwirtschaft haben die
die menschheit zweimal ernähren könnte
sterben jährlich 18 millionen menschen
an hunger
es darf nicht sein dass menschen wegen
der höhe des profits verhungern müssen
80 personen auf der welt besitzen genau
so viel vermögen wie 35 milliarden
menschen also die finanziell untere
hälfte der menschheit absurd wir sind
also die partei die am entschiedensten
für soziale gerechtigkeit kämpft der
kapitalismus hat aber auch große
schwierigkeiten ökologische
nachhaltigkeit durchzusetzen
wir stehen vor einer klimakatastrophe
ökonomische interessen sprechen zum teil
gegen ökologische das ist das problem
des kapitalismus wachstum ist übrigens
ein positiver begriff
es ist nicht klug zu sagen dass man
gegen wachstum sei weil die menschen das
dahingehend missverstehen dass man ihn
etwas wegnehmen dass man ihre
lebensqualität einschränken will
in wirklichkeit bedeutet aber
ökologische nachhaltigkeit ein wachstum
an lebensqualität das muss man
herausarbeiten die
die herannahende klimakatastrophe zeigt
dass wir vor menschheitsfragen stehen
menschheitsfragen lassen sich nur
beantworten wenn es eine struktur für
weltpolitik und ein primat der welt
politik über die wirtschaft gibt
menschheitsfragen lassen sich nur
beantworten wenn es wenn die
gravierendsten probleme liegt am
gravierendsten sozialen probleme gelöst
es muss eine angleichung der
lebensverhältnisse auf allen fünf
kontinenten geben damit sich die
menschen ihren menschheitsfragen stellen
eine familie die an hunger leidet
interessiert sich weder für ökologische
nachhaltigkeit noch für pressefreiheit
außerdem zeigt dies dass die
industriegesellschaften ernsthaft
beginnen müssen die fluchtursachen zu
bekämpfen nicht die flüchtlinge
die herstellung der herstellung sozialer
gerechtigkeit ist also auch eine
wichtige aufgabe wenn man ökologische
nachhaltigkeit erreichen will und
deshalb ist es so richtig und wichtig
wenn wir von sozial ökologischer
nachhaltigkeit sprechen
was also im kapitalismus funktioniert
muss bleiben und weiterhin funktioniert
und was nicht funktioniert und ungerecht
ist das müssen wir versuchen zusammen
mit anderen zu überwinden drittes ich
möchte euch heute etwas zu einer
möglichen regierung mitverantwortung im
bund sagen ich kann dies jetzt völlig
frei tun weil ich mit sicherheit einer
solchen verhandlungsdelegation nicht
angehören werde und nicht die geringste
absicht habe bundesminister zu werden es
gibt bei uns viele wirklich nicht die
geringste es gibt bei uns viele die eine
regierungsverantwortung anstreben und es
gibt solche die sie nicht wollen
letztere können das aber nicht zugeben
und werden nur für sehr viele rote
haltelinien streiten die man auf gar
keinen fall unterschreiten dürfe in der
hoffnung dass spd und grüne schon an der
zweiten haltelinie scheitern und ich
kann das durchaus verstehen
mitverantwortung für die nato die
bundeswehr schon die europäische union
ist in gruseliger ehrlicher wäre sie
sagten einfach dass sie dagegen sind
aber sie wissen dass sich 90 prozent
unserer wählerschaft wünscht dass wir in
einer regierung verantwortung übernehmen
das hemmt zehn jahren aussagen
ich finde übrigens im unterschied zu
vielen bei uns haltelinien jeglicher art
die andere parteien kaum kennen
für falsch weil sie einen misstrauen
gegenüber der eigenen behandlungs
delegation zum ausdruck bringen ein
misstrauen dass wir gar nicht nötig
haben
wir beschließen wir beschließen ein
wahlprogramm das ist die richtlinie die
vorsitzenden der parteien wären die
verantwortlichen für solche
verhandlungen
misstrauen gegen sie ist nicht
gerechtfertigt dabei ist doch eines klar
man muss kompromissfähig sein aber man
darf seine identität nicht verlieren die
schritte können nach unserer auffassung
zu kurz sein aber sie müssen in die
richtige richtung gehen und liebe
genossinnen und genossen wir sind eine
10 prozent partei keine 50 prozent
partei das müssen wir zunächst zur
kenntnis nehmen außerdem müssten bei uns
die mitglieder der partei über eine
koalition im bund ohnehin durch
urabstimmung entscheiden
die gesellschaftliche akzeptanz die wir
inzwischen erreicht haben ist über viele
jahre gewachsen und schwer erarbeitet
worden dass wir kaum noch aus dem
bundestag wegzudenken sind dass sie
menschen im land die linke inzwischen
schon weitgehend für selbstverständlich
erachten sollte uns selbst bewusster
machen
es ist uns gelungen das politische
spektrum der bundesrepublik deutlich
nach links zu erweitern was vor 1989
völlig undenkbar war
das ist eine historische leistung wir
haben deutschland was die linke betrifft
europäisch normalisiert und müssen nun
uns selbst ebenfalls normalisieren es
wird z
es wird zeit unseren erfolg anzunehmen
und den nächsten schritt zu gehen also
alle formen des politischen agierens in
den ländern und dem bund als
selbstverständlich wahrzunehmen als
normalfall unserer politischen arbeit zu
begreifen
wir haben die mitverantwortung durch
mitverantwortung durchregieren bisher
auch als mittel betrachtet
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz zu erringen
dann aber macht man vielleicht das eine
oder andere zugeständnis zu viel
dann ist man vielleicht das andere das
eine oder andere mal zu wenig
selbstbewusst wir können und sollten
auch auf bundesebene regieren wollen und
zwar selbstbewusst mit kompromissen aber
ohne falsche zugeständnisse
eigentlich sollte man nie sagen zu
welchen kompromissen bereit wäre weil
das spätere verhandlungen nicht
erleichtert sondern erschwert ich begehe
aber mal diesen fehler um die
bereitschaft unserer partei zurück
selbst wenn wir nicht jeden
bundeswehrsoldaten aus dem ausland
zurück beordert bequem aber es schafften
dass sich deutschland an kriegen wie
gegen jugoslawien gegen afghanistan
gegen den irak gegen libyen bei allen
kampfeinsätzen auf keinen fall während
unserer regierung mitverantwortung
beteiligte welch ein gewaltiger
fortschritt wäre dies wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich schaffen wir es nicht
dass es keinen waffenexport mehr gebe
aber wenn wir erreichten dass es keine
waffenexporte mehr entspannungs gebiete
und an diktaturen gebe welch ein
gewaltiger fortschritt wäre dies
natürlich schafften wir es nicht die
europäische union völlig umzukrempeln
aber wenn statt sozial und
demokratieabbau ein mehr an sozialer
gerechtigkeit und demokratie entstünde
welch ein gewaltiger fortschritt wäre
dies stellt euch ein aufbauprogramm für
griechenland durch eine solche regierung
vorangetrieben vor welch ein gewaltiger
fortschritt wäre dies wenn es uns
gelänge die tdp verhandlungen wenigstens
auszusetzen und damit in der zeit
unserer mit regierungsverantwortung zu
stoppen
welch ein gewaltiger fortschritt wäre
dies eine erfolgreiche zeit der
aussetzung könnte das ganze auch nach
einer regierungsverantwortung von uns
zum stoppen bringen
wenn uns im verhältnis zu russland
deeskalation gelänge wenn auch russland
in europa wieder integriert werden würde
und dadurch auch das
selbstbestimmungsrecht des ukrainischen
volkes wieder hergestellt werden könnte
welch ein gewaltiger fortschritt wäre
dies
natürlich gebe es auch bei einer
regierungs mitverantwortung von uns noch
geheimdienste und die nse wenn es uns
aber gelänge selbstbewusst gegenüber der
us regierung aufzutreten verhandlungen
über ein neues abkommen nicht
vorzutäuschen sondern zu erreichen
die massenüberwachung und die
wirtschaftsspionage zu überwinden die
vorratsdatenspeicherung zu verhindern
sowie die eigenen geheimdienste deutlich
einzuschränken und wirksam zu
kontrollieren
welch ein gewaltiger fortschritt wäre
dies stellt euch vor wir könnten die
zustimmungsrechte der betriebsräte und
personalräte erweitern und die prekäre
beschäftigung deutlich zurück arbeiten
zurückdrängen
bei weiteren drei arbeiten hätten
zumindest ab der ersten stunde
arbeitszeit anspruch auf 110 prozent des
lohnes den jemand aus der
stammbelegschaft für die gleiche arbeit
in dem unternehmen erhält damit würde
leiharbeit zur ausnahme werden und die
stammbelegschaften nicht mehr über sie
unter druck gesetzt werden können der
niedriglohnsektor könnte viel effektiver
bekämpft werden befristete
arbeitsverhältnisse gebe es nur noch mit
sachgrund und nicht willkürlich der
missbrauch von werkverträgen könnte
ausgeschlossen zumindest zurückgedrängt
werden welcher gewaltiger fortschritt
wäre es wenn wir den druck erhöhten
endlich für gleiche arbeit in gleicher
arbeitszeit in ost und west den gleichen
lohn zu zahlen
und wenn wir durchsetzen dass man in ost
und west für die gleiche lebensleistung
die gleiche rente wird sie
welchen gewaltigen fortschritt bedeutete
mehr steuergerechtigkeit
es könnte uns gelingen die
steuerfreibeträge für den ärmeren teil
der bevölkerung zu erhöhen
die kalte progression und den steuert
auch für die mitte der gesellschaft zu
beseitigen und den spitzensteuersatz
angemessen zu erhöhen
natürlich müsste auch die
vermögenssteuer wieder erhoben werden
ohne die kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen dadurch zu schwächen oder
gar kaputt zu machen welchen gewaltigen
fortschritt bedeutet es endlich eine
angemessene und stabile finanzierung der
kommunen zu erreichen was nur über
umverteilung und steuergerechtigkeit
verwirklicht werden kann
ich sage euch offen
in den letzten fragen sehe ich die
größten schwierigkeiten beim ringen mit
spd und grünen
dasselbe gilt für unsere vorstellung die
rente grundsätzlich zu reformieren
in der nächsten generation wollen wir
das alle mit erwerbseinkommen in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung einzahlen
wir können ihnen berufsständische
versorgung und private versicherung aber
es ändert nichts an ihrer pflicht zur
einzahlung in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung und das ohne
beitragsbemessungsgrenze
wer ein hohes einkommen erzielt muss
eben auch einen beitrag von dem hohen
einkommen bezahlen und für
spitzenverdiener muss die rentenerhöhung
abgeflacht werden
dann hätten wir gute grundlagen das
rentenniveau zu erhöhen so dass die
menschen eine rente bezögen mit denen
sie den lebensstandard aufrechterhalten
könnten den sie sich im erwerbsleben
erarbeitet haben altersarmut könnte also
abgebaut und dann überwunden werden
durch eine veränderung des
versicherungssystems könnten wir
erreichen die zwei klassen medizin zu
überwinden und eine ausreichend
finanzierte gesundheitsvorsorge und
gesundheitsfürsorge zu gestalten die
sich ausschließlich nach der art der
erkrankung des menschen und nicht nach
seiner sozialen stellung richtet wir
könnten die pflege so finanziert
bekommen dass sie sich nicht nach
minuten sondern nach den bedürfnissen
der betroffenen richtet schwierig wären
auch die verhandlungen zu einer
sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung
entschieden müssen wir uns für deutlich
bessere bildungseinrichtungen und
chancengleichheit vor allem für alle
kinder in der bildung einsetzen und für
die überwindung der schlechten bezahlung
der sogenannten frauenberufe wir müssen
versuchen die gesellschaft dafür zu
öffnen das nicht nur gleicher lohn für
gleiche arbeit sondern auch gleicher
lohn für gleichwertige arbeit erreicht
werden muss
deshalb gilt dem arbeitskampf der
erzieherinnen und erzieher der
sozialarbeiterinnen und sozialarbeiter
unsere volle solidarität obwohl wir die
gewaltigen probleme und sorgen der
eltern die nicht mehr wussten wie sie
ihre kinder unterbringen sollten gut
verstehen und nachvollziehen können aber
den erzieherinnen und erziehern den
sozialarbeiterinnen und sozialarbeitern
blieb und bleibt kein anderer weg
und dass endlich die homo-ehe käme wäre
wohl selbstverständlich
liebe genossinnen und genossen
wenn es jemals zu verhandlungen kommen
werden sie schwer aber wir alle haben
nicht das recht uns vor schwierigkeiten
zu drücken und außerdem brauchen wir
auch etwas neues
immer nur zu sagen wir sind und bleiben
opposition und gehen auf gar keinen fall
in eine bundesregierung ist für die
akteurinnen und akteure langweilig und
für die wählerinnen und wähler wenig
überzeugen aber leicht ist es nicht in
die regierung zu gehen und trotzdem
gesellschaftliche positionen zu bleiben
aber ich denke wir können das schaffen
ich finde wir sollten diesbezüglich
offensiver fordernder werden und spd und
grüne stärker unter druck setzen
mit anbiederung hat das nichts zu tun
sondern mit dem wunsch nach schnellen
realen gesellschaftlichen veränderungen
veränderungen erreicht man auch in
opposition
aber eben nur deutlich schwieriger und
langwieriger und wenn sanierungen oder
koalitionsverhandlungen scheitern dann
darf das nicht an uns liegen sondern an
spd und beziehungsweise oder den grünen
denn sie stehen doch vor dem eigentlich
schwierigen fragen will die spd zur
alternative für die union werden oder
deren anhängsel bleiben wollen die
grünen zur union gehen oder das
gegenüber stärken
aus diesen schwierigen fragen sollten
wir sie liebe genossinnen und genossen
nicht entlassen
darauf kommt es mir an
viertens eine wichtige frage für unser
image besteht auch darin ob wir eine
partei des verbieten oder das erlauben
es werden jede und jeder von uns weiß
dass es bestimmte von bothe geben muss
aber ich empfehle entschieden dass wir
eine partei des alarms werden ich war
mal auf einem landesparteitag in einem
bundesland in dem wir noch nicht in den
landtag eingezogen waren es uns übrigens
bis heute noch nicht gelungen
auf jeden fall wurde über das
wahlprogramm diskutiert und dann stand
ein delegierter der sie
sportwissenschaftler nannte auf und
erklärte dass er als
sportwissenschaftler wüsste dass
sämtliche europa und weltmeisterschaften
schädlich für die sportlerin und
sportler seien und deshalb vorschläge in
das wahlprogramm die forderung nach
einem verbot von europa und
weltmeisterschaften in diesem bundesland
aufzunehmen und wenn ein wissenschaftler
so etwas sagt hat es die mehrheit aus
sofort beschlossen
ich habe mich gefragt wir sind noch
nicht einmal im landtag aber die leute
sollen gleich wissen dass wir ihnen ein
vergnügen streichen
warum könnte man nicht beschließen über
solche fragen diskutieren zu wollen
weshalb muss es gleich ein
verbotsbeschluss sein fünfter
natürlich müssen wir eine partei bleiben
die rassismus antisemitismus faschismus
und jede form von nazitum entschieden
bekämpft
deshalb steht uns auch keine arroganz
gegenüber dem sogenannten kleinbürgertum
zu im gegenteil wir müssen versuchen es
zu gewinnen dürfen es nicht dem
rechtsextremismus oder rechtspopulismus
einfach überlassen
übrigens mag ich leidenschaftlich
engagierte auch radikale leute aber
keine extremisten und extremisten
schon weil sie frei von humor und
toleranz sind
dass rechtsextremisten furchtbar sind es
klar linksextremisten können auch mehr
als unangenehm sein
übrigens tierschützerin und tierschützer
sind wichtig aber fanatische
tierschützerin und tierschützer sind mir
auch unheimlich ich glaube sie mögen
menschen nicht besonders
wenn wir diese fünf punkte stärker
beachteten können wir uns endlich aus
dem zehn prozent wert bei den
bundestagswahlen nach oben entwickeln
und auch außerparlamentarisch eine
bedeutendere rolle spielen
ich möchte heute die gelegenheit nutzen
kurz für mich resümiert zu ziehen als
ich 1989 entschied in die politik zu
gehen meinte ich nicht einmal im ansatz
was auf mich zukommen sollte hätte ich
es gewusst hätte ich es wohl nicht getan
aber vielleicht ist es ein vorteil dass
man nie genau weiß worauf man sich
einlässt wie ich eingangs sagte haben
sich die akzeptanz unserer partei und
auch meine akzeptanz in der gesellschaft
deutlich erhöht ich habe ja nicht viele
fähigkeiten aber eine ich kann ziemlich
gut mit sehr reichen leuten mit mittel
reichen leuten mit unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern aller couleur vor allem mit
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern auch
mit rentnerinnen und rentnern mit
bäuerinnen und bauern mit beamtinnen und
beamten mit jugendlichen besonders gerne
mit kindern mit menschen mit
behinderungen mit arbeitslosen mit
flüchtlingen mit asylbewerberinnen und
asylbewerber mit hartz iv empfängerinnen
und hartz4 empfängern mit obdachlosen
und vielen anderen reden keineswegs
immer unstreitig aber reden
das müssen wir glaube ich alle lernen
und ich habe immer versucht
und ich habe immer versucht die
politische sprache zu übersetzen
unser ziel muss sein verstanden zu
werden
ich will und kann gar nicht einschätzen
was ich in der ersten reihe der politik
in den letzten 26 jahren geleistet habe
aber ich glaube schon dass ich einen
anteil an den möglichkeiten haben habe
die wir uns inzwischen erschließen
können ich glaube auch dass ich einen
anteil am gewachsenen respekt haben und
ich bin auch ein bisschen stolz darauf
dass wir inzwischen in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik den ersten
ministerpräsidenten stellen der links
von der sozialdemokratie organisiert ist
ich freue mich dass ich einen anteil
daran habe dass man über einen
demokratischen sozialismus im
kapitalismus wie der ernsthaft
diskutieren kann und das herausragende
persönlichkeiten linke persönlichkeiten
der deutschen geschichte nicht vergessen
sind
das gilt für karl marx und friedrich
engels für wilhelm liebknecht und august
bebel für rosa luxemburg und karl
liebknecht für clara zetkin verkalkt ski
und eduard bernstein und viele andere
auch für linke internationale
persönlichkeiten wie antonio gramsci die
ich aber nicht schaffe auch nur
einigermaßen vollständig aufzuzählen
gilt dass wir einen beitrag geleistet
haben und auch künftig leisten müssen
dass sie nicht aus dem gedächtnis der
gesellschaft gestrichen wird
ich habe eine bitte an euch macht aus
alledem was draus das leben in der
ersten reihe der politik hat seine vor
und nachteile die eitelkeit wird schon
durch den hohen grad der bekanntheit
befriedigt es gibt auch kleine vorteile
da bekommt man gelegentlich noch plätze
oder karten die es eigentlich nicht mehr
gibt
man hat aber vor allem mehr einfluss auf
veränderungen des zeitgeists man lernt
persönlichkeiten kennen an die andere
gar nicht herankommt
ich kann sie nicht alle aufzählen aber
besonders stolz bin ich auf mein treffen
und gespräch mit nelson mandela eine der
herausragendsten persönlichkeiten der
letzten jahrzehnte diese kraft diese
toleranz diese großmütigkeit nach über
20 jahren haft bei ihm fast
unvorstellbar
all dies war für mich in diesen jahren
eine große bereicherung aber die
mitgliedschaft in der ersten reihe der
politik hat bei mir auch spezielle und
generell gravierende nachteile
man steht unter ständiger öffentlicher
kontrolle
ich habe viel zu wenig freundschaften
gepflegt ich hatte viel zu wenig zeit
für meine angehören
und das lag nicht an euch ihr mich
eingeladen habt das ist eurer recht ist
es sogar eure pflicht auch nicht an den
anderen die mich ein blumen sondern es
lag an mir
weil ich zu selten nein sagt sagte mich
einfach zu wichtig
das ist eine große gefahr wenn man in
der ersten reihe der öffentlichkeit
steht
ich werde andere nicht davor bewahren
können aber bei meinen angehörigen
meinen freundinnen und freunden
möchte ich mich heute aufrichtig
entschuldigen es tut mir sehr sehr
leicht zum schluss will ich allen
mitgliedern seiner partei will ich allen
sympathisantinnen und sympathisanten
unserer partei will ich allen
wählerinnen und wählern unserer partei
bin ich aber auch denjenigen die zwei
unserer partei nicht wählten aber mir
ihre stimme gaben
will ich gehen die das alles nicht waren
aber unsere partei immer fair
begleiteten und auch denjenigen die dies
war nicht wollten aber immerhin mich für
begleiteten würde ich meinen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter meinen
freundinnen und freunden und meinen
angehörigen die ich heute hier begrüßen
darf vor allem meiner schwester gabriele
meiner langjährigen partnerin andrea in
dieser zeit meiner vorherigen partnerin
monika meinen kindern anna georgi und
daniel euch und ihnen ein wort danke